[Musique]
détention de plus en plus vives entre la
République démocratique du Congo et le
Rwanda qui gagne accuse notamment
Kinshasa d'avoir violé son espace aérien
et d'avoir arrêté deux de ses
ressortissants
au Sénégal cette manifestation à Dakar
cet après-midi de nombreux sénégalais
réclament des explications au
gouvernement après un rapport accablant
de la Cour des comptes concernant la
gestion de fonds débloqués en 2020 pour
lutter contre le covid-19
et puis vous découvrirez à la fin de ce
journal une rétrospective de l'année
2022 en Afrique l'actualité a été dense
avec notamment l'organisation de la
canne au Cameroun ou encore les deux
coups d'État au Burkina Faso
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur France 24
on ouvre cette édition du Journal de
l'Afrique avec ses tensions entre la
République démocratique du Congo et le
Rwanda en cause l'arrestation de deux
rwandais par les autorités de Kinshasa
ils sont accusés d'avoir préparé un
attentat en RDC le Rwanda se dit très
préoccupé par l'arrestation de deux de
ses citoyens les explications de notre
correspondant à Kigali Clément dire
romain
les deux rowlandais détenus par les
renseignements étaient au Congo depuis
plusieurs années et travailler pour la
même ONG de développement fondé à Genève
et basé à Kinshasa l'un d'eux le docteur
Juvénal chimie mana était auparavant
employée des Nations unies dans le pays
l'arrestation des deux hommes en août
dernier n'a été rendu public que lorsque
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
rwandais a demandé à son homologue leur
libération immédiate en novembre dernier
une demande restée sans suite puisqu'ils
sont encore en détention aujourd'hui et
ont même été accusés par le
vice-ministre de l'Intérieur congolais
et les porte-paroles de l'armée et de la
police en direct à la télévision de
faire partie d'un réseau d'espionnage il
aura fallu attendre un nouveau pic de
tension entre la RDC et les Rwanda pour
que Kigali s'exprime encore sur cette
affaire le gouvernement se dit préoccupé
par ses détention et pointe du doigt la
RD Congo affirmant je cite que ces
dirigeants cherchent à alimenter la
division ethnique et pointe du doigt des
forces extérieures fin de fin de
citation alors pour Kinshasa ces espions
présumés sous couvert de leur ONG
infiltré des cercles militaires
politiques et économiques mais aussi
obtenu des accès et même en patrimoine
fonciers à proximité de sites
stratégiques dans la capitale congolaise
en vue de préparer en attentat l'enquête
continue selon les autorités
autre point de tension entre les deux
pays le Rwanda accuse la RDC d'avoir de
nouveaux violets son espace aérien ce
que réfutent Kinshasa les précisions de
notre correspondante en République
démocratique du Congo Aurélie bazarra
kibangula
aucun des deux avions de chasse n'a
survolé l'espace aérien rwandais c'est
ce qu'affirme le gouvernement congolais
dans un communiqué diffusé hier soir les
autorités congolaises évoquent un vol de
routine d'un avion de chasse qui a je
cite survolé entre autres le lac qui
vous dans l'espace aérien congolais
alors se communiquer est une réponse de
Kinshasa à une nouvelle accusation
rwandaise selon Kigali un avion sous koï
25 a violé l'espace aérien rwandais se
survole ses produits mercredi à 12h le
Rwanda parle d'un incident qui fait
partie d'une série de provocations le 7
novembre un avion de même type avait
déjà non seulement survoler l'espace
aérien rwandais mais il s'était posé
brièvement à l'aéroport de roubaro avant
de repartir côté congolais Kinshasa
avait évoqué un survol Malan contre eux
alors ce nouvel épisode fait monter un
peu plus la tension entre les deux pays
rappelons que la RDC accuse le Rwanda de
soutenir le M23 un groupe rebelle qui a
repris les armes dans la province du
Nord qui vous des accusations également
emportées par plusieurs diplomaties
étrangères et un rapport des experts des
Nations Unies malgré tout Kigali
continue à rejeter ses accusations
et sur le terrain en République
démocratique du Congo des affrontements
ont encore été signalés dans le
territoire du ruthourou des combats qui
opposeraient l'armée congolaise aux
rebelle du M23 dans cette zone les
habitants continuent de fuir leur
village souvent à la va vite sans
pouvoir prévenir leur famille pour cette
raison le Comité international de la
Croix-Rouge a mis en place des cabines
téléphoniques afin que les déplacer
puissent rester en contact avec leurs
proches regardez ce reportage d'Aurélie
bazarra kibangula est juste un kaboumba
depuis plus de 4 semaines niabazindé n'a
pas de nouvelles de sa famille cette
grand-mère est arrivée seule au camp de
kayarochinia après avoir fui les combats
entre l'armée congolaise et le M23 à
l'autre bout du fil sa fille est née
j'ai enfin réussi à joindre ma fille
j'étais en quête que la situation n'est
pas bonne elle m'a dit que tout allait
bien et qu'elle cherchait à venir ici au
camp avec mes petits-enfants
comme elle de nombreux déplacés du
territoire de route Chourou ont perdu
tout contact avec des proches cette
cabine téléphonique a été mise en place
pour leur permettre de prendre des
nouvelles
ce jour-là le téléphone est pris
d'assaut nous notons tous les appels sur
des fiches en trois heures nous avons
enregistré 80 appels gratuits par jour
on attend en général 120 appels ici
l'espoir tient parfois un simple bout de
papier sur lequel est inscrit le numéro
d'un proche cette jeune femme a eu moins
de chance le numéro qu'elle tente de
joindre ne répond pas
mon beau-frère ne répond pas je n'ai pas
de nouvelles de ma sœur ni de ses
enfants je suis très inquiète les
combats ont repris les nouvelles de
route ne sont pas bonnes au total 5
cabines téléphoniques similaire ont été
mises en place dans les camps de
déplacer du Nord qui vous la priorité
est donnée aux enfants qui ont fui seul
les combats mais impossible pour eux de
retrouver leurs parents en tant que
désaffrontements sont en cours on essaye
justement à travers aussi le téléphone
et les volontaires que nous avons dans
différents endroits de pouvoir faire
marcher les activités de rétablissement
des liens familiaux depuis fin octobre
plus de 520 000 personnes ont été
forcées de quitter le territoire de
route Chourou selon les Nations Unies
toutes comme dans des abris de fortune
dans des conditions inhumaines
20 ans de réclusion criminelles c'est la
peine à laquelle ont été condamnés 46
militaires ivoiriens soupçonnés d'être
des mercenaires par le Mali ils étaient
jugés pour attentat et complot contre le
gouvernement mais aussi atteinte à la
sûreté extérieure de l'État quant aux
trois femmes militaires libérées par
Bamako début septembre elles ont été
condamnées à la peine de mort par
coutumas
[Musique]
on prend maintenant la direction du
Sénégal ou la colère commence à monter
au sein de la population une
manifestation a eu lieu tout à l'heure à
Dakar pour demander au gouvernement de
rendre des comptes concernant la gestion
des fonds de lutte contre le covid-19
ces fonds avaient été débloqué en 2020
et le rapport de la Cour des comptes les
concernant est accablant les précisions
de notre correspondant à Dakar Eliman
Dao
ne seront pas digérés c'est le principal
mot d'ordre en wolo fantonné par les
manifestants qui sont rassemblés en
début d'après-midi à la place de la
Nation pour réclamer la lumière sur la
gestion des fonds en covid 19 il s'agit
de 1000 milliards de francs Cfa à dégagé
par le gouvernement du Sénégal et ses
partenaires en 2020 pour la riposte
sanitaire économique et sociale contre
la covid 19 et la Cour des comptes a
publié un rapport à notre rendu public
il y a deux semaines un rapport qui note
des fautes de gestion des infections
pénales présumées et également des
conflits d'intérêts de façon générale de
malversations qui ne sont pas au goût
des manifestants je vous propose de les
écouter
l'argent n'est pas aux populations ils
ont tout gaspillés c'est ça c'est pas
normal il y a pas une seule personne qui
n'a pas de parents qui est décédé de la
covid et alors en ce moment là on était
confrontés à une guerre contre la covid
des personnes se mettent à détourner
l'argent public je pense que ça c'est
très grave que tous les personnes qui
ont été épinglées viennent nous dire ce
qui s'est passé réellement pour qu'on
sache la vérité le rapport demain
aussi les sanctions pécuniaires pour que
les choses soient et que plus jamais des
gens comme ça n'arrive dans ce pays-là
selon le ministre des Finances qui a
fait une sortie publique de la semaine
dernière
99% des fois à louer à la riposte contre
le covid 19 ont été bien gérés à des
explications loin de convaincre les
manifestants et la société civile
c'est la plus longue compétition à la
voile de l'hémisphère sud et elle
s'ouvre lundi la 50e édition du mythique
cap to Rio parmi les participants
sibousissos 6 atouts un ancien berger
sud-africain il relira la pointe sud du
continent africain au Brésil son
portrait avec Laurent berthetcher
6 atouts a déjà 9 ans lorsqu'il aperçoit
l'océan pour la première fois
vingt ans plus tard cet ancien berger
s'apprête à larguer les amarres
direction le Brésil pour la 17e édition
de la cape to Rio une véritable
consécration pour ce jeune skipper
sud-africain qui a dû en convaincre plus
d'un que sa place était sur un voilier a
commencé par sa famille
encore aujourd'hui ne comprennent pas ce
que je fais la seule chose qu'il me
demande c'est si je gagne de l'argent tu
travailles est-ce que tu travailles
depuis le township du Cap will Gandhi la
voile apparaît comme un passe-temps de
riche retraités et majoritairement blanc
mais lorsqu'une association vient dans
son école proposée des stages de voile
aux jeunes défavorisées si Boussy sauce
saute sur l'occasion et prend vite le
goût du large aujourd'hui capitaine d'un
équipage de 5 personnes il a su
surmonter les préjugés il espère que son
parcours pourra servir d'inspiration à
d'autres jeunes navigateurs
pour ceux qui n'y croyaient pas
quelqu'un comme moi qui a grandi dans un
township peut traverser l'océan jusqu'à
Rio
j'espère jusqu'à l'avenir il y aura plus
de personnes de couleur représentées
dans ce sport
prêt à mettre les voiles si Boussy Sow
et son équipe partiront lundi de Keith
Town pour une traversée transatlantique
de près de 7000 km
et avant de refermer ce journal de
l'Afrique le dernier de 2022 je vous
propose de découvrir une rétrospective
de ce qui s'est passé sur le continent
cette année une année est chargée en
actualités avec notamment la Coupe
d'Afrique des nations au Cameroun ou
encore les deux coups d'État au Burkina
Faso c'est une rétrospective signée
Laurent berthetcher
24 janvier 2022 le président du Burkina
Faso rock Marc Christian caboret et
renversé dans un coup d'État il est
remplacé par le lieutenant-colonel
Paul-Henri sandao qui fait de la lutte
anti djihadiste sa première priorité la
restauration de l'intégrité de notre
territoire comme priorité absolue
passera par une réorganisation de
l'ensemble des forces combattantes mais
sur le terrain la situation sécuritaire
continue de se dégrader provoquant des
tensions au sein de l'armée le 30
septembre d'amyba est à son tour
renversé par le capitaine
Ibrahim Traoré ce dernier promet un
retour à l'ordre constitutionnel en
juillet 2024
l'année 2022 aura également été marquée
par la fin du conflit on Éthiopie la
guerre sanglante opposant les forces
gouvernementales au rebelles du TPLF a
pris fin début novembre avec la
signature d'un accord de paix entre les
deux camps fin décembre les
communications ainsi que les connexions
aériennes entre 10 à Beba et mécaniques
commencent à être rétabli laissant
espérer le retour d'une paix durable en
Éthiopie
autre conflit majeur de l'année
l'insurrection du M23 en RDC le groupe
qui avait repris les armes fin 2021 a
enregistré des avancées majeures à
l'automne s'emparent de vastes pans de
territoire au nord qui vous et
s'approchant dangereusement de Goma le
conflit aura également ravivé des
tensions avec le Rwanda voisin accusé de
soutenir le M23
l'année 2022 aura aussi apporté son lot
de bonnes nouvelles notamment sur le
plan sportif finaliste malchanceux en
2019 le Sénégal remporte la première
Coupe d'Afrique des Nations de son
histoire mais c'est surtout la
performance du Maroc au Qatar qui marque
les esprits défions tous les pronostics
les Lions de l'Atlas deviennent la
première équipe africaine a atteindre
les demi-finales d'une coupe du monde
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information continue
sur France 24
[Musique]